i couldn't be more excited to take this
journey with you
i feel like i just met my husband
oh my god would you call it love at
first sight
it was one of those things where i had
never felt it before claire do you fall
in love early with dale do these guys
stand a chance
we are joined now by the bachelorette
claire crawley
claire we've been waiting for this one
for a long time
how are you feeling about people finally
seeing your season
are you nervous or do you think it'll be
some vindication that you're ready for
i'm so so ready for this that obviously
the build up
was taking forever so it's like when it
finally came for me
to film this and to get going on this
season it was like ah
but now it's kind of been a minute since
we filmed it so it's like
yeah i'm excited for everybody to see
this and definitely see a side of me
that
i've never shared with people before and
a vulnerability that
i hope people can appreciate and relate
to so claire the big question for any
bachelor bachelorette
are you in a relationship are you
engaged
you know goodwill i cannot spoil that
come on now
okay are you happy right now
yes i'm very happy are you in love right
now
i can't answer okay well
so we have an exclusive clip of
tonight's season premiere and it's a
moment where we see you talking to blake
and confronting him kind of about him
being the only person to reach out to
you during
the quarantine production stop down
during the quarantine claire posted on
instagram on a story
that she was really struggling right now
because of
what her mom is going through in the
hospital so i want to
check in if she's okay over quarantine
yeah it was really hard for me and
you were the only guy that reached out
to me the entire time
was blake the only person you talked to
during all that
blake was the only person that messaged
me the only person i had any contact
talk to any sort of communication with
it was one of those moments where
you know we're given these rules to
respect the process of it all and i
definitely 100
respected the process what he did i also
and the reason he did that i also really
respected
so okay so blake was the only one
yes correct and you gave him the first
kiss
yes so we like blake
blake is a really sweet guy hi
come on over player my name is dale
let's talk about another moment we've
seen
you meet dale and oh wow
it's a dale of a tale you say i think i
just met
my husband tell us i feel like i just
met my husband
[Music]
oh my god how did you know
it that one of those things where i had
never felt it before and i never
even knew what to expect with those
feelings when you have not experienced
it or felt it
you don't know if it exists but when you
feel it
you know exactly what that feeling is so
were you right about that feeling
you'll have to say just standing in
front of a man
connecting on that level and it being
electric between each other i've never
felt that instantly like that before
would you call it love at first sight
i would i would definitely call it you
know
i don't know i don't know what you'd
call it let's call it electric
okay let's talk about more uh of this
episode
claire here are some of the things you
say about dale on the premiere
quote i definitely feel like i just met
my husband
i felt everything i haven't felt ever
i'm 39
you know these things i know what i know
when i feel that feeling
claire that all sounds so sure and so
like
love it for sight was this love at first
sight and how did you know this man
was your husband i don't
know like i said it was one of those
intangible
goosebumps all over the body like just
what just happened and to for me being a
confident woman i could
i honestly stood there all night and i
was like great to meet you i'm excited
like each guy i was so into i was so
happy to meet him
and then with dale i felt like i was
just a blubbering mess
i was like what did i just say did it
sound okay and what just happened
so for me to be caught off guard and
maybe at a loss for words
i think that definitely says a lot well
chris comes over chris harrison and he
says
a lead has never said something like
that on night one
so what kind of conversations did you
have with producers
considering you'd just done something no
one had ever done before and kind of
named your husband
at a limo entrance i was laughing with
conservation about it because i was like
is it not that obvious for other people
when they have that connection and he's
like
not like that i guess i assume you never
know when you watch it on tv because
i've never been the lead before i've
never been the bachelorette this came
out of my mouth
but did the producers do you talk to
them and do you say i don't know this
might be the one
the yeah there's definitely a lot of
conversations that are had behind the
scenes of like this guy
this guy caught me off guard on that and
that guy it was a hard no
um and you can already tell how's your
um
how's your attention who doesn't you
give him the first impression rose that
night you talk about that natural
amazing connection you have in that
conversation
but then we also hear you say things
like you wake up thinking about him you
go to sleep thinking about it and we see
sexy kisses
just talk about that connection both
physical and mental emotional that you
two have
yeah that was something that you can't
really anticipate with anybody you don't
know
just as much as i was feeling them i
didn't
expect or know like was he feeling that
are we on the same page
usually in my experience as
relationships goes there's always
somebody that's ahead of the other
person or
it's really rare that you kind of
connect on that same page at the same
time um
so it was just it was one of those
magical things that
i guess just happens um we see some sexy
moments between you and dale some kisses
and at one point
you are in bed together is that a
fantasy suite do you
have fantasy suites and and is that you
and dale in there
is that dale i mean clearly we're in a
bed together
what is i can confirm that is dale and i
in there is it a fantasy
suite you'll have to wait and see you'll
have to wait and see this
this season is like no others claire do
you fall in love early with dale did
these guys stand a chance
help me because you call him your
husband claire
i'll let you guess that then if you're
if you look at that if you're seeing all
the scenes and
watching us kiss if that's what you're
taking from it then
what do you want did she look dale up
and kind of know she might connect with
him
first of all i find it funny when people
are like you
admit that you looked him up how could
you not
i don't know there was no convince the
rules of
going on social media and looking at
people's pain i feel i could be doing
myself a disservice to not
do my research i agree i'm going to be
my future husband
i want to know what they're doing in
their off time in quarantine
i want to know what they're keeping up
with and what their type of content
they're posting is it them partying is
it them
with a bunch of women or is it that
their family
and i think with dale um to answer your
question
in a lot of his stories he would talk
about his mom or he would talk about his
family he was with his family a lot and
that is something that
deeply resonates with me um and i just
felt
on any level whether it be friendship
whether it be a romantic connection i
knew
i just felt like there would be that
good connection with him
um but you you ultimately don't know if
it's a romantic connection
because you're just seeing them through
social media we also see in the teasers
the guys question dale's authenticity
it's only a matter of time before claire
realizes the truth
that dale's maybe not who claire thinks
she is is that legitimate do you feel
like you
knew the real dale absolutely i knew the
jail that
was in front of my face i think i've
experienced it before in the past where
people you're not there for bromances
you're not there for anything more than
that and i know to some it can sound
harsh but it's the reality of it is that
that's a fun part of it is the bromances
or the friendships
that is innately going to be a part of
it but ultimately you want to find love
and how he is to my face that's what i
care about how do you share
there's there's i'm sure there's a lot
of stuff that he shared with me that a
lot of guys shared with me that they
didn't share with the other guys
well the men seem to stage some kind of
walk out
i want to get crazy let's get crazy how
about
the 15 of us walk out what is that about
do they
quit the show um
you wanna the truth is i didn't see that
part that was news to me so i had not
seen that
oh wow well so there wasn't a point to
your knowledge when the men quit the
show and walked out
not to my knowledge let's also talk
about a much teased moment chris
harrison telling you
you just blew up the bachelorette
congratulations you've just blown up the
bachelorette
what does that mean you blew up the show
i think he's basically referring to that
this is a season like no
other and i could say that really
confidently being a part of this
franchise for a while now
um it was one of those things where
there was a lot of different things that
played into it being such a dynamic
different season that i think it's
definitely gonna blow people's minds
what does it mean to have blown up the
show claire
i don't know ask chris that that's a
good question
well it was a long build up to night one
what was your emotional state like going
in
because you seem really to be feeling
things
yeah there was so much emotion because
not only all the coveted stuff all the
quarantine to be
kind of like trapped inside our homes
for six months and not have any
for me i didn't have any contact for it
was me by myself and so going into this
i just had so much
gratitude for this opportunity and still
even now in the world it's crazy people
are kind of sort of dating and it's that
weird you're having to wear a mask and
six feet apart stuff so um to have this
opportunity i just
always was overwhelmed with like they're
doing this for me
you know they believe in me and want to
find love for me
just as bad as i want it so do here in
the teasers we hear
one man say i didn't expect the process
to be cut
short i didn't expect the process
to be cut short and we hear another say
so do we get a new bachelorette i can't
even fathom how you guys are going to
try and process this
i don't know what that means like okay
do we get a new bachelorette in here
so claire claire it up for me is tasha
the new bachelorette after you
cannot confirm or deny anything all i
can speak for is my journey and my story
on this
right now i'm here i'm talking to you
i'm the bachelorette well does the
process get cut
short um
i do things my way and uh we'll see
we'll see if it does i can promise you
that i stayed
the entire time your twitter account
liked a tweet about tasha being the
bachelorette
clear up what happened there was that
you and what did that mean as we
leave and go go film these shows
everybody has
other people who run and kind of monitor
their accounts and
um my my
friend was helping me run mine and she i
don't think she fully knows how to run
twitter
why did she like that tweet the truth is
i don't even know her and i have not
even talked about it
i didn't even think of a big of a deal i
think slip ups happen or
whether she meant to or didn't mean to i
haven't we haven't even talked about it
i mean clear the thing is you're the
bachelorette so people are monitoring
your socials like crazy so everyone went
nuts over that if i was the one that did
it i would totally own it because i've
said it before
on my twitter i years ago like i wanted
not years ago i wanted
as the bachelorette a while ago like i
support her i think she's beautiful
i think she's a very grounded woman and
woman who knows what she wants
um i completely support that i've
supported her
i wanted her to be the bachelorette
forever i always was for that
okay so you would feel fine with tasha
being the bachelorette at some point
are there words are there two
bachelorettes this season
i can't i can't say i don't know well we
also see in a teaser
someone says claire's gone do you quit
the show at any point
i did not quit the show okay you stay
the whole time
okay um i went i
i did what i was gonna do there i showed
up
um i didn't quit didn't quit anything
well do you have anything you would have
done differently on your season
any regrets anything you would have done
differently with the men and the
experience that they had
would i change anything do i have any
regrets i no
because i followed my gut and i really
paid attention to
does this serve me and if it didn't um i
took care of it and if it was something
that
aligned with me i did it and whether or
not it was
um aligned with what the plan was of the
season or what like i
followed my gut to the very end and i
can't regret that ever
you know you have talked a lot about
your parents importance to you um
that dvd your dad made about wanting to
bring somebody home to meet your mom
so where are you at with that journey
have you brought anybody home from this
season to meet your mom and has anybody
watched that dvd yet
uh that's a part of this story and i
think it's an important part of this
story because especially with the
pandemic and all this kind of this
bubble that we're in
um this season is definitely going to be
different how it plays out is definitely
different i think it's going to be one
of those things that
people are really going to have to watch
to appreciate and to
respect that well i have to ask you matt
james was supposed to be on your season
things have gotten crazy scheduling wise
and now we know he's the bachelor
what's your reaction to that because
there was some talk about you you guys
having a little twitter shade and
controversy
so where do things stand with you and
matt i don't know matt personally
um i think that he as the bachelorette
he's got something that he's always
wanted and i'm excited for him to
start this journey i knew it was
something that was in his forefront
always so
for him to have this opportunity uh
couldn't be more excited for him
are you saying you think he always
wanted to be the bachelor
uh yeah you do
i'm not saying in a negative way i'm
just saying i i think it was no secret
that he always wanted to be the bachelor
so you kind of felt like that was why he
was coming on your season in the first
place
um i don't know i never talked to him
personally about it
i just can go off of um
conversations that have been had
messages videos that were sent to my dms
and
all that kind of so like i said it's not
a negative thing it's not a bad thing if
that's what he wants and
that's his goals with things more power
to him like he's the bachelor
i'm excited for him for his journey and
i have nothing but respect for him
claire last question uh we hear you and
chris in that conversation he tells you
the path we're on is not good for anyone
you or the guys
you're in tears the path we're on right
now
it doesn't end well for you for the guys
for anybody what comes out of that
conversation what's that path and where
do things go
my whole goal in all of this was for
everybody
to know and understand that even though
i'm the bachelorette and this
is my personal journey to find love it's
also their personal journey to find love
as well
they went through all the testing that i
went through they put themselves on the
line they put their jobs on
hold they put their families on hold
all to find love and have their journey
as well so for me
i wanted to do everything i needed to do
to respect these men
and to make sure that there was no
leading people on or no disrespect to
anybody
period describe your season in one word
unpredictable as ever
describe your connection with dale in
one word electric
[Music]
electric